you
[Music]
happy monday you naughty little mixers
would it do what it do want to do what
it is um hope you've had a good week
thus far
guys you already know the drill we need
to start chirps and more things in the
comments so we can build up the
relationship so that when we move to hq
of the cult
in the big green field we've got
breeding territories
so that we can make this last generation
yeah um so
if you're on youtube guys click
subscribe
click the notification bell so you know
when the next thing drops
flip in
like the video and chirp sitting in the
comments that's all we ask for you know
that's not all we asked for literally
it's literally it um
help us help you and help the masses
okay
um
obviously you already know if you're
sitting here and you're loving this
monday vibe and you just think it's just
not enough
it's just it's just not enough it's a
healthy advertiser but it's just not
that way you can't wait it's another
seven days yeah seven days is too long i
want to binge
that's where the part is at okay that's
where the vibes are wrapped
um do i get it said it best bro
it only costs you three pound a month
temperature tempe a day okay one has to
pee
run the pee it's so basic it's so simple
it's like it's like a step-by-step plan
we
we patent it for you all you have to do
is follow instructions yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's sorted all you need to do is
follow through
um
obviously if you guys are listening to
the audio on spotify upper podcast make
sure you subscribe and make sure you
leave us a nice review
um
we're running running hard at five stars
at the minute so it's looking good it's
looking good guys um so you tuned into
the second biggest podcast in the world
with your boy j money fire lord for
example dragon of the west he's gonna
hit us with some fun facts let's buckle
up and get into a good monday let's go
come on let's go right there's a 10 year
old girl that can retire after 15
after at 15 sorry after earning a
hundred and five
thousand dollars in one month
you saw i saw this yeah i haven't read
anything about it i saw it and i was
like starred
yeah man i'm going to talk about this
yeah what's she made out of sketch
what's she doing
um this australian little girl called
pixie curtis has a has already
established two successful businesses
with the help of her mother an accessory
range called pixie bows and a toy range
called pixie fidgets
the mother daughter duo first launched
their pixie bows in 2011.
estimates say pixie will earn
over 21 million dollars over the next
decade in may
her line of fidget toys sold an
impressive 200 000 in a debut month
she also has 89k instagram followers
and charges up to 600 000
for a sponsored post by the time she was
six
for one sponsored post six she thinks
she's kim kardashian six hundred
thousand dollars for one sponsored price
that doesn't make any sense no one's
paying that surely no one's paying that
what's going on nah fam how many
followers
uh 89 bags
is that it
eight well then she must have more now i
was gonna say well i'm that's not she
wasn't charging half a mil for 89k
followers was she no she couldn't have
yeah that's she couldn't
i don't know you think you are bro she
couldn't have wow that's
kids love fidget [ __ ] yeah that's the
thing they love fidget [ __ ] we spoke
about this a few episodes ago about the
top 10 uh youtubers
oh ryan's toys and stuff yeah yeah
was number one yeah that's just like
ryan's slaying [ __ ] man just two two
toys a couple of toys fam
we might have to start doing some
reviews on some techno stuff you know
unboxings i'm boxing some [ __ ]
because that's where the moneys are
apparently these men are killing it you
man what should be on box
but i don't want to buy it
send us a site we can unbox buy it for
us send it and i will unbox it we'll
talk about it we'll give you the specs
and all sorts yeah cause that
is matter it doesn't make sense bro yeah
these don't make p for [ __ ] hell
[ __ ] hell little kid the thing is i
love how they like are with the help of
her mother her mother's dictating that
whole show the whole she's not seeing
that p till she's 21. yeah her mom's
living lavish lavish yeah bro oh my god
i love that [ __ ]
they love that [ __ ] that's crazy bro bro
just doesn't things like that just don't
make sense so she made 200k in a debut
month and that's her second business
that she's dealt with yep
wow
wow
that's the money money yeah yeah um fair
play man that's all i can say you never
have to work a day in a life fair
[ __ ] play this is literally all i can
say because that's literally all i can
say as well
that's um yeah that's nuts um before we
get into what you want to get into yeah
um i've got a quick trash news yeah and
i've got a game i want to play oh okay
go on
cool so quick trash news there's a
florida couple that got nabbed for
license violation
having sex in a police patrol car and
they filmed it for their only fans
brave ally
summer watkins and jordan now
both 24 engage in sexual activity after
being placed in a patrol car when
noah sorry they spoke his name wrong
twice i don't know which one it is let's
go with noah yeah um when noah was
pulled over for driving with a suspended
license earlier thursday morning
watkins allegedly told noah
baby we should record an only fans video
while we're back here minutes before the
couple began having oral sex according
to the minutes after sorry the couple
began having already oral sex according
to the arrest report
noah was taken from the car sooner soon
after and arrested by another trooper
over control substances that they were
that they had discovered in a car
um perez morales is the the lady then
dropped watkins off at the gas station
minutes later the paris morales video
reviewed video footage on the prologue
minutes later the perez morales reviewed
video footage from the paroled car
the trooper quickly returned to the gas
station and arrested watkins
she was charged with lewd and
lascivious i don't know that's
pronounced that word this am i going to
presume it's lascivious behavior and
breach of breach of the peace you know
wow
noah was charged with possession of
controlled substance possession of
marijuana breach of peace indecent
exposure of a sexual organ oh yeah and
leaders and leads of lascivious behavior
and both defenders were taken to county
jail after being arrested
they were each released on bond within a
day and december 13th court date has
been set for noah and watkins is
expected to to be in court on december
16th and this is them
oh she's kind of sexy yeah i can i can
see them doing a little oh yeah
yeah i'd like something like regardless
of where we are
yeah yeah yeah i can see that i can see
the appeal of it yeah you're catching
lucious behavior as well
i don't know if that's how you pronounce
the word but it sounds like the word
that's nuts she's got them lips she has
got them dsls yeah yeah she has got them
dick sucking lips for sure for sure wow
oh god that's brave fam is brave and
it's like
what are they making on only fans to
think like this yeah it's worth getting
arrested for
they're already they're already in the
whip they're already arrested they said
[ __ ] it let's let's try and make it
bigger to be fair if you're already
there why not when are we going to get
this chance again it's probably never
going to happen again mad mad indeed
mad indeed
so they weren't even they weren't even
cuffed clearly
clearly unless you unzip the thing with
it
what is that what the man did this
and how did he just yank to allah damn
that's naughty that's nice
if i was the police i'll be the whistle
i'll be the worst police officer
if i'm right inside enough and i'll just
be
if i'm writing up a ticket and i just
peek over and then man's getting slopped
off in the back of my wig
i pretend i don't see nothing
i'm not a hater bro i'm not a hater ah
i'll let them do what they need to do
what you need to do because it's
probably the last time yeah yeah you're
not gonna see each other for a while do
what you need to do especially if i'm
gonna charge them anyway yeah yeah yeah
yeah big man do you think might as well
complete the task yeah yeah do you think
do you think do you think you're going
to need that bell money
because you're not going to see daylight
so i hope this slop is worth it oh [ __ ]
yeah i'll let them finish off [ __ ]
other jokes that's oh that's wild she
vex when homeboy said he reviewed the
thing and then skirt the thing back
around to get her she was livid when he
rocked back up
hundred percent living hundred percent
that's wild she should have dipped from
that gas station oh my days that's wild
for [ __ ] [ __ ] people are crazy um
more trash news hit me a bit annoying
because burma recording this is going to
be a week behind
[ __ ] i just found out tommy fury
backed out of the fight i read that on
the train here he's he replaced it with
somebody they've not said why yes yes no
one said why because you're [ __ ] or
that's why
that's the only excuse i can think of
unless someone in your family is dead
it just i don't want to hear it yeah oh
following that i've i've got tyron
woodley back
so that again
replacement yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but i've
had something somewhere about
um tommy
on my phone somewhere but continue
anyway continue i've got it somewhere
but yeah so obviously he's out
as of today when we're recording this we
don't know why hopefully by the time
this comes out we will
know why
um
but yeah man i'm not happy i'm not happy
at all i'm not best pleased um
not not even in the case of i was
looking forward to the fight i was just
looking forward to
the result yeah i don't care about the
fight i didn't want to see the fight
yeah i would have watched it but i don't
actually care i just
ah
i don't know bro i just don't understand
what could have possibly
i just don't get it fam literally
in my head
for this thing the way he's been
chatting the way his dad said if you
don't knock him out is his ex if the way
his brother said if you don't knock him
out his ex just order this chat for a
week before
man said is off
and what's going on what is going on is
your mom in hospital is everything all
right what is going on what is literally
what is going on the pops is a savage as
well they said i found the fact that i
was going to talk to you yeah i had this
on my phone for a random reason so in
2011 john fury father of tyson fury was
found guilty of wounding with intent to
cause grievously bodied heart bodily
harm after street fight in 2010 he
gouged a man's eye out with his thumb
and left him half-blind that doesn't
surprise me just bang yeah it doesn't
surprise me at all he's a [ __ ] animal
yeah it doesn't surprise me at all [ __ ]
you know man yeah doesn't surprise me at
all bro [ __ ] he's traveller man they
don't care about him gypsy king and the
father yeah yeah don't care about them
animal bro yeah bro yeah all of them are
mad sir i'm not surprised zombie got
shook on just i'm gonna go
he was i'm allegedly saying he's not
sure yeah yeah because like he it's it's
too much pressure for one man the way
everyone's telling him if you lose his
curtains
i'm not surprised he thinks he's not
poor he don't need this money the
money's going to be healthy it's going
to be more money than he's ever made
probably but he don't need it he's
comfortable yeah so yeah for your family
to be like it's curtains for you if you
don't win this fam it's literally
literally curtis now that he's pulled
out
it's curtains but there's always a
reason you can say why you pulled out
he's never gonna say because i'm shocked
he's gonna make up some kind of [ __ ]
reason
why either broke his wrist or he got
knocked out and sparring and flipping
saturn happened he's probably he'll
probably come under something happen
during training
as to why he can't do it and he's going
to pick it up as soon as he can and it's
never going to happen
tyron woodley's back in tyrone woodley
who's i don't know anything so tyron
woody was his last fight
jake
jake's last fight okay former ufc
what
what what wait was he i can't remember
what way maybe welterweight um
he used to be uc champion okay former
ufc champion
savage absolute savage so that was
jake's last fight
really disappointing fight jake
obviously won
tyron woodley is a decent boxer
i have a sneaky suspicion that fight was
fixed why
well so
during the fight
there's a couple times so jake won on
points right
there was a couple times in that fight
where tyron rocked jake's jaw off he
nearly put him through the ropes he
rocked him and jake was half out of the
ropes
yeah and then when
jake's back up again
the the time to attack
he darn didn't do anything
so he could have won it that'd be a
hundred percent found okay when he boxed
him through the ropes as soon as he got
back into the ring one more bang jake
would have been out
and that happened like twice where he
rocked him hard and then just didn't
finish him and i was thinking that was
suss at the time and then literally as
soon as tyrone lost
there was no kind of this is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
there was no kind of oh [ __ ] it you know
what i lost i lost it was literally as
soon as you lost where you can take this
one of two ways you can take it as
competitive or you can take it as like
i'm just money hungry as soon as jake's
hand got lifted up tomorrow's like
rematch rematch rematch run the rematch
run the rematch run the rematch let me
take your money run the rematch run the
rematch run the rematch as obviously
tom's retired as a fat payday for him
so
rematch on the cards was already for as
soon as he lost he said rematch thing
like immediately i'm ready
i was
thinking there would never be a rematch
if you knocked him out yeah the whole
thing would have been done if you
knocked him out yeah yeah that never
would have happened yeah but if you took
the l yeah
then there's a plausible rematch
especially if it's a close fight yeah
and jake wins then it's a plausible
rematch ergo we've got a rematch now
yeah um and he he jake even said i'll
give you a rematch if you get um i love
jake paul tattooed on you and tomorrow
is like bet
and he's actually got i'm pretty sure
it's on his finger he's got like a
little i love jake paul tattoo and i
don't know if it's real or if he just
died it did it in pen but came out a
couple months ago like okay where's the
rematch he took pictures our rematch
thing like he's desperate for this cake
[ __ ] again and i was just like i wasn't
impressed yeah i really was not
impressed um so we'll see how the second
fight goes because there ain't gonna be
a third so we'll see how the second
fight goes hopefully tyron just comes in
and says cool i'm glad i've got my
rematch
like drops it was it was all games last
time yeah drop first round run me my p
and i'm out i'm praying to god
that's what happens i don't know if that
is what's gonna happen but i'm praying
to god it does because if he loses to
him again i'm done bro
tommy i'm done with you and tyron i'll
be done with you i'll be done with the
whole affair yeah comes in here and
loses again
i just haven't got time for it on 18th i
think
i'm assuming the only the only clause is
is incredibly short notice for tyron
woodley um
of course incredibly short notes what's
he gonna do he's got two weeks
he's gonna get knocked out that's [ __ ]
all you can do in two weeks he's gonna
get knocked out he ain't getting knocked
out i don't think he's gonna get knocked
out
tomorrow he's retired no he's retired
but he's still a [ __ ] animal i don't
think he'll get knocked out
we'll see i don't know i don't know i'll
be i'll be embarrassed for him if he
does i'll be embarrassing him if he gets
knocked out um let me see what tyron
woody looks like
i don't know he's got legs on him i
don't follow boxing at all like that but
he's not a boxer oh he's a ufc fighter
oh ufc rover tyrone woodley said okay
the first thing that came back they're
listening brother
they're listening they are they are they
are [ __ ] me
oh i feel he looks familiar yeah he's a
warrior fan he's a warrior yeah he's
jack massive yeah he's sure
jake's much taller than him
he's like five eight five nine i think
jake's like six foot maybe
jake's got size on him now though a bit
jake's got size on it now yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he's got size on it got a bit i'm not
gonna lie to you yeah and he's boxing
day in and day out that's the thing he's
not i'm not even trying to say he's he
ain't [ __ ] yeah he he can he can fight
tomorrow is a former ufc champion fan
he's a warrior fair enough
very [ __ ] love he's been fighting his
whole life
damn yeah but yeah intriguing intriguing
um we'll see how it goes i'm not
impressed with tommy bro neither am i
when i saw that i literally saw that on
the train down here i was like oh not
even in the case of i was looking
forward to the fight everything i just
wanted to see the aftermath yeah who won
yeah bro because it's all been chips
up so yeah you need to know what's it
about
yeah it's i'm not happy about that at
all
yeah it wasn't cool man um
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it just his ways i guess there's
nothing we could do it's what it is
i don't know if he's gonna like i said
at this point he's there's been no kind
of release or anything so i wanna see if
what his excuses and if he's gonna even
try and pick it back up
but
i already know what's going to happen
he's just he's literally just going to
be like ah
something went wrong in training i'm
injured or i'm concussed or sat in as
soon as i get back on my feet this fight
is back on um
jake paul the youtuber is a is a [ __ ]
chitch and i would smash him whatever
like it's whatever and then he's gonna
give it a chat for about a week
until it all
bubbles down and then he's never you'll
never hear of it again again
you can't show his face and then
whenever anyone asks about it he'll
literally just say bro my agents have
been hollering him day and day out he
don't want it he don't want the fight i
know how these games go they always go
this way when one person ducks out they
try and save face for years and they're
always like bro i've been asking him for
months and months i've been on the phone
to him trying to get this fight he don't
want the fight there's a reason he's
scared today he's just going to do it
for time and time again and jake's going
to be like bro i sent proof of funds to
his yard last week and no one i ain't
heard nothing
it's all it's definitely what's gonna
happen it's always [ __ ] it happens
that's so that's a show it's dead bro it
is dead and like i wasn't even looking
forward to the fight anyway but when
that happens you're like
why
i can understand if jake pulled out he's
supposed to be here yeah he's not
supposed to be here yes it's a lot more
embarrassing yeah so it's like i need to
know what happened to you bro for you to
pull out because you've been chatting
like say you can smack him up with your
eyes closed so what's going on that you
can't fight this my man in two weeks
two weeks which is long enough to sort
yourself out yeah regardless regardless
regardless yeah regardless yeah yeah
unless he's got like a broken toe yes
unless you've broken a bone or something
i don't know what's happening
we'll see i'll see him about him manny
anyway
i'll see him about it i'll ask him
between now and then you ain't seeing it
i know i'm not he's not leaving this
year i've seen it for months i already
know it's time your drive passes eggs
all over it
eggs and tissue paper fab
the mug oh
[ __ ] you know
it's literally not on
oh well um so
for the first time ever
we've got a cheeky
bit of back and forth beef i sent you
earlier
in the dms
yeah
cheeky bitter back and forth beef that's
darius i've never seen anything like it
because i looked at the dates i was like
one was in november yeah or september
and then the one was the other day i was
figuring i didn't even patent that yeah
fam
mad because the thing is i hadn't even
um
i hadn't even seen it
let's have a look see
so the first one from back then i hadn't
even seen
until today which is when i saw this
first one as well i realized it was uh
all right you're connect
so
for context guys we received a message
from
23rd of november when we got from this
uh young lady
who said
i have an ick for men
when you're having car sex
and he wants to do you from behind
so gets his bare pale ass out of the car
in the freezing cold and starts hitting
it from behind whilst putting a dent in
your door with his knee
icky behavior
as i'm scrolling through i see another
dm
am i the [ __ ]
am i the [ __ ]
i was beating out this girl doggy in her
car and ended up denting her car door
with my knee smashing against it she
wants me to pay for the den i said nah
fam
then at the bottom she watches the
podcast too so let her know man ain't
pain
you heard it here first guys
man ain't paying
me
yay pays [ __ ] oh
that's hilarious sweet me when i say i
can't believe it
neither could i because it's one of the
odds first and foremost
but i'm trying to envision
how he's backshotting the chick and his
knees dent in the car
so in my head because
continue continuing our now trying to
vision in my head
they're just
out of the car isn't it so she's in
oh she's got her legs out and her body's
in bent over he's out
and he's got a leg up or satin and his
knee is smashing against the door
sighting like that bro
i don't know how it's worked but it's
working yeah i'm just thinking i was
even but anyway yeah
he must have been smashing to get his
knees
his knee was doing something that's all
i know he must have hit it more than
once yeah thinking
i would have stopped after the first
donk like fam my knee hurts she resents
donnie from when she got his pale bear
ass
nah ah don't hold me up like that ah she
hated him she hated him that day she
hated him that day oh that's hilarious
pale don't
don't run from my cheeks like that are
you gonna send for my skin tone
oh on live tv pod two so man ain't
paying ain't paying for [ __ ]
fam so
fair play hers is a ick or whatever to
his
what's your actual opinion should he pay
or should he not pay um
say it's you
i mean i wouldn't necessarily say i'm
flat out not paying
because it's a two it takes two to tango
kind of thing cool but within the same
breath
i don't know it would have to be it'd
have to be something like
let's say she brought up to me or i said
oh [ __ ] whilst i was [ __ ] i didn't
even clock i did this kind of yeah you
know
my [ __ ] bad you know yeah i was
heating a moment blah blah and we
decided to go half ease
i'll be okay with that yeah you know
yeah yeah but
it all it also depends on
how the conversation started was she
like you're [ __ ] paying for this
that's what i was thinking she's but
she's it's probably gone down like nah
you're [ __ ] paying for this
we did this we made this exactly yeah
yeah let's let's talk about this like
nah [ __ ] that you're paying for this i
can't afford this that's how we might
hate it panda that's probably why it's
like yeah definitely teller ain't paid
for [ __ ]
tell her on the live show i ain't paying
for [ __ ]
bro
that's exactly what my thought process
was
in terms of if it was me
i would offer yeah
and be like look
that i i accept some responsibility for
this i i do think two to tango kind of
thing
but i do accept some responsibility if
you want to go half's or if i can
country let me know how much cost i will
contribute what i can contribute and
stuff like that i'm sorry et cetera et
cetera then that's what i would have
done immediately so when he said
um because actually no no i saw his
before i saw hers okay so when i read it
i was thinking you're not a man cause
you know i mean when i first read his i
thought you're not a man bro
just you're just denting out yes and
saying tell her on the pod i ain't
paying i think you think you are prof
but then you read hers as well even
though she hasn't said i told him to pay
or anything when you read it you do
think a bit like ah i do wonder if the
circumstance was you're [ __ ] paying
for this
then he might have been a bit like hang
the [ __ ] on 100 percent it would have
yeah because there's no way she i don't
see her
saying his palace and blood like that
came from the depth like that's where
that's vengeful you know that's
revengeful she she was upset when she
typed it yeah yeah yeah so it 100 would
have been a case of she instigated the
conversation or said like oh you have to
[ __ ] pay for this and he's like whoa
i ain't paying for this [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know yeah yeah
that's how i see it that's how i see it
um i do think he should be a man and do
something though because when you if
we're gonna get logistical
it's his fault 100
is actually his fault of course and not
her fault at all of course of course of
course if your knee makes contact with
my car
that's all of your fault of course now
granted the only responsibility i would
accept is that it's my car and i can't
make you pay [ __ ] so i'm never going to
come with smoke like big man you're
sorting this out because immediately i
expect them to be like suck out yeah
literally bye
bye your car your problem yeah i nutted
i dented i'm out
i'll leave while she's still better you
can't make me do anything i'll take my
pale bear [ __ ]
kiss this playlist goodbye
[ __ ]
yeah bro um but yeah if she came with a
humble thing
if she did let's okay let's not put all
the earnest on her aggression if she did
actually come at him on a humble one and
say
yo
i can't afford this like can you or even
if i can afford this i'd even if she
said i do think though you should be
helping me to pay this because
it's your fault yeah yeah yeah and he
still says no then he's a balance
hundred percent 100 percent he's about
100 people not man you're not man you're
not 100 you've got to take some
responsibility of that if that's the
energy she came in if that's the energy
but we need a little bit more context
yeah so i'm expecting dms from both
parties and we can hash this out me and
fred are going to mediate this thing
let's just see
that's what we're here for both of you
you know who you are
um
young lady send us your send us the full
break now send us your point of view
young man send us the full breakdown and
we're going to mediate this we'll go
from there we'll see who's lying kevin
samuel glasses on and we'll find out
where the truth lies yeah because like
we said in the previous episode there's
your story that's her story and there's
the truth we're going to get to the
bottom of it
you can't swindle us
around this block yeah am i the [ __ ]
block we've been around it bagger time
yeah we know
because if one of you man's if i see a
block of missing information in these
things
we're going to send for you we're coming
for you we're going to send me
and we're going to have to sign a
contract because someone has to pay the
p yeah someone has to pay
literally yes someone needs to pay for
this so we're going to get to the bottom
of it and we need both of you to to
respect our verdict at the end of the
day whatever we say goes we're the judge
yeah we're the judge
if we say man my man it's your fault you
have to slide at a p and we say darling
i'm sorry
it's your fault or
no you didn't want to meet in the middle
brother then we'll go from there
we'll see oh i'm excited yeah so much oh
i'm excited you better send us the
[ __ ] reviews yes we never ask for
check-ins yeah we never we don't do
sometimes we do but it never happens but
this one has to happen yeah yeah we need
this we need this because this is recent
this is very recent so i know you're
both going to watch this episode so yeah
send send us the reviews send us the
reviews
i'm excited
um
you said you want to play a game
i was thinking about this on the train
on the way down
so um actually no that's a lie i thought
about it last night and then i continued
it on the train have i got one two three
four five six i've only got eight so far
i want to do ten but i wanted to see
if you can guess the full names of
certain anime characters
guess so i'm gonna say
the first name i'm going to say the main
name and see if you can guess the second
name if that makes sense okay i'll try
so for example naruto uzumaki boom okay
cool so that's not a guess
oh it's a guess because you're guessing
but you know what i'm guessing but i try
to remember okay
oh no basket yeah
all right cool cool cool cool cool cool
so there's titles and characters on
whatever no i just guess no no no not
the name of the show the name of the
character oh so no basket is not the
name no i thought you were saying no
basket for reference oh right no oh oh
coraco uh no idea
can you hazard a guess
i have no idea
ah
it's all coming back in it yeah
you're vexed yeah yeah yeah that's
pissed me off isn't tetsu his actual
first name though
yeah but he's known as corrupters as i
put the main known name so it's easier
for you to okay because if i said
tetsuya would you have i would have
gotten i wouldn't yeah i wouldn't have
all right cool there we go fair play
fair play fair play um midoriya
he's right there yeah i know
know you do um midoriya uh you know
about her names bro
um
what's the beginning with
i
izumaki and yuga and for some reason i
knew you were going to say that but no
it's wrong
because izumaki is naruto
that's uzumaki as well
what is it
all right cool this is gonna go badly
man all right i'm just gonna get naruto
and that's it
ichigo
ah um now i'm getting mixed up with
kuroko
close though here's a k kurasaki yes
gang all right cool cool cool cool gang
gang gang you're getting there getting
there getting there all right
all right
naruto by the way
oh okay
from um haiku
yeah hinata
um
what's the beginning of s
not my [ __ ] idea show you
show you uh yeah yeah i can't deal with
this bro you're stressing i can't deal
with this bro all right i'll give you an
easy one all right aaron
[Laughter]
yeah yeah all right uh tanjiro
tanjuro
where's he from again
jiu jitsu
no no that's a lie he's from um
demon slayer
oh yeah tangelo
um someone did this
demonstrate
tangelo
oh
i don't know man
[ __ ]
uh
i don't know
what to begin with okay
they all begin with k
uh
i don't think i slept enough last night
know
i don't think i slept enough last night
i have no idea
come on dude
i wasn't gonna get that i know you would
speaking of i've got one more but
speaking of apparently
uh demons lays out
apparently apparently right now yeah but
i've not i've not researched it i saw it
on twitter i said oh do you miss the new
seasons out but i'm not such but we'll
have a look
um
last one
uh itadori
it's a dory
from
my hero
no
where's it from
jiu-jitsu
oh of course it is
does it begin with k as well no
what's to begin with
why
your face
eugene yes
that was terrible you got four out of
eight though uh okay that's not that bad
okay that's not that bad i wanted to do
ten but i couldn't think of that jesus
christ i'll do more another time i'll
think of [ __ ] you know i'm so bad with
names it's painful bro i know it's
painful i need satin you need like an
image
yeah yeah and he starts out my brain
work bro because it's just not it's not
brainy
it's just not working you're afraid it's
not braided and i was just a quick
little game [ __ ] all right cool i'm
annoyed about that i know you are i did
a um
a friend's quiz the other day i know too
much about friends okay oh the actual
show friends oh thinking okay yeah do
you mean some of the questions
do you watch a lot of friends i've seen
them all you've seen it all i've seen it
all like twice oh okay let's do a very
quick friends quiz gang let's do that
you've done all of these ones already
right yeah i've done them all do you
remember what you what you got like the
score or whatever uh
i think i got two wrong out of i can't
even remember hang on oh maybe this is
different ones
i don't think this is the the same one
okay calm that's fine all right cool so
i won't know so this is the one you have
to answer it but then i won't get the
answers till the end okay
okay all right okay we'll smash for it
quickly okay
question one why does monica throw a
christmas summer party during season two
um
because the rest of the gang are
depressed because joey refuses to eat
anything
yeah i thank the lord because she wants
to find a good looking date
because her heating
system breaks say them again sorry
because the rest of the gang are
depressed yes because jerry refuses to
eat anything but ice cream
yeah because she wants to find a good
looking date or because our heating
breaks
probably the third one because she wants
to find a good looking day yeah i feel
like that's monica's energy
that is her energy i feel like uh what
does the holiday armadillo want ben to
learn about the
um what is what does the holiday
armadillo want ben to learn about in the
season seven christmas episode okay
uh ross's new girlfriend
how to be emotionally open
paleontology or his jewish heritage
it's i think it's either c or d
say the question again
what does the holiday armadillo want ben
to learn about
the
the jewish
heritage yeah cool
which festive outfit does phoebe dress
up in to collect money for charity
the grinch an elf santa or a reindeer ah
i was gonna say santan i think it is
santa okay i think so
cause i remember she stood outside like
a shop with a with a ting with a bucket
thing i remember which of ross's
girlfriends freaks him out by suggesting
they sent out a holiday card together
mona elizabeth charlie or bonnie
i don't remember any of them i don't
know who they are
ross's girlfriends he's had girlfriends
he has so i'm pretty sure if i remember
correctly
i kind of remember
charlie's the black one
i know that was in later seasons yeah
yeah bonnie i'm pretty sure it's
phoebe's friend that shaved their head
or is that mona
is one of them thingy's um sister he
dated rachel's sister as well no
oh
isn't that one of them
is that what their names again mona
elizabeth charlie and bonnie i think
elizabeth is the english chick now yeah
i think so
bonnie's the black chick who was the
other two
and
monar owned bonnie
elizabeth and charlie
and the question is
[ __ ] out bro you're taking longer
sorry i'm trying to think bro i'm trying
to win here the only reason i'm saying
is because we're eight percent of the
way through it's gonna take all day oh
jesus sorry fam um let's just go with
body all right cool
why is it so long fab can i not skip to
the end
why is this one so long phoebe is
distraught when she sees old christmas
trees being thrown in the chipper how do
monica and joe joey make her feel better
convincing her that trees are happy and
heavy heaven by breaking the chipper by
taking her to plant a new tree or by
buying all the old trees
probably the first one
cole i think phoebe's gullible like that
cool
in season six rachel and phoebe search
monica's apartment to find out what she
has bought them for christmas where do
they find the presents
i do remember this episode as well what
are the options under the window seat
behind the fridge in her closet or in
the roof space
i think it's the window seat
yeah i think it's the window seat
cool i know all of these apart from that
girlfriend one i think i've got them all
right during season three ross
accidentally causes a girl scout to
break her leg during her christmas
cookie run how did he make it up to her
uh getting everyone to sign their name
on uh on her cast dressing up as santa
and bringing her the presents selling
the cookies himself or buying her a
ticket to visit nasa i think it was
sending the cook to c
it was i can't
uh
in season i'm gonna try and make this
last one this is going on for too long
season 9 the gang are faced with the
prospect of spending christmas presents
spending christmas day without chandler
why can't chandra be there
so in season 9 the gang are faced with
the prospect of spending christmas
without chandler why can't he be there
he refuses to celebrate christmas
he and monica have broken up he got
trapped in an atm vestibule he's working
in tulsa
the last one working in tulsa
cool right
how do i skip to the end so we can see
what we got because this has taken on
[ __ ] day
i wasn't expecting some of these
questions boy well if that was kind of
questions [ __ ] hard no yeah man i
thought they're gonna be easy things
um i feel like it's gonna be a massive
waste of time because you have to deal
with them all before you can see the
score yeah i don't think he's going to
let me do it and we're literally 18
percent through
that's going to take an hour to get
through
um
yeah we'll figure it out see what one
which one's worked um
can i go back
because i can tell you got something
wrong
um
but no you did okay um i'm pretty sure
phoebe was an elf
okay i think she was an elf but you're
right when she was standing outside i
remember
yeah yeah i remember that the christmas
seat for the presents was correct i know
that episode um you got the christmas
tree wrong wrong
with uh phoebe yeah yeah it was they
bought all the trees okay and she walks
in and all the [ __ ] trees are in the
yard ridiculous
um
you were right about ben's jewish
heritage
um
i kind of remember what any of the other
ones were the girlfriend wanted to go
with [ __ ] names
christmas card
i have no idea which one that was oh
actually um
ross's girlfriend was one of them mona
charlie bonnie and someone else i'm sure
he said yeah which one was maybe
actually no
which one was bruce willis daughter i
thought that might have been elizabeth i
don't remember bro i remember the bruce
willis daughter incident where they go
to that stay away vacation place spring
break spring break and ross rock's up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah waist man i remember waste man
i remember and he's hiding under the bed
when bruce willis comes in yeah yeah
yeah i remember yeah for the life i
would never remember her name though but
yeah yeah jesus
fam
ridiculous another waste of time because
we don't even know what we got so guys
so there's two wasted games
apologies we tried to spice it up it
went terribly wrong i can't think of
anyone's name say in my life and i
couldn't get the answers to who had's uh
friend's quiz so ruined ruined that's
what you get when you don't prepare
um and then you try and think of
something on the cuff uh off the cuff
even i said on the cuff one time in a
jigsaw clip and someone buried me in the
comments really yeah it was harsh um
but c'est la vie
um so i've got two little things
first
um
someone sent us in
well actually i say someone a few a good
few people sent us in this tick tock
of a woman
asking what's the most embarrassing
stuff uh said during sex
okay
and
the comment section
i'm here for her already
i'm here for it already so let me
actually open the tick tock see what it
says
so what's the most embarrassing thing
you've done during sex answer in the
comments
bro these comments
right
stuttered whilst talking dirty and got
embarrassed
[Laughter]
that would ruin the whole that's an ick
bro bro that would ruin the whole thing
started
nah nah nah lock the whole thing
fam that's hilarious horrible
yelled chupapi migneno when he put it in
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
man lined up the team
never heard that before
you have to say that
as in the yacht said that or the guy
said that what the [ __ ] does that even
mean it doesn't mean what is it
what is that
stop stop
i don't know what that is it doesn't
mean
i'm itching bro it doesn't mean anything
okay
it's just a dumb
reaction noise
okay so it's just like
how do i explain it
it's just a weird sass kind of [ __ ]
reaction noise okay so i can't think of
a good example okay but it's supposed to
just ruin everything okay do you know
what i mean okay it's one of them okay
so it's like it's the kind of noise that
if you were sitting in a room by
yourself
and i was hiding in the closet
i would scream that to the top of my
life yeah yeah okay okay yeah okay it's
just weird it's just a dumb weird stupid
tic toc never heard of it you've
that surprises me
that surprises me you get that in
on the playstation all the time
when you're just got the open chat on
and people chat [ __ ] online chip up in
minion
told him i loved him and he went soft
bro
michael said i love you and man's tool
said nah
that's too much [ __ ] that's embarrassing
fam that's in and
i don't blame women sometimes you know
because sometimes when they heat at the
moment and they're getting good dick
the elbow just it just leaves your lips
it just drops out it's not their fault
yeah yeah it's practically our fault
yeah
fam oh it's out of order [ __ ] he went
soft that's not even in his control
either
it's a mental thing [ __ ]
there's issues all over the gap there
this one's clean this one's clean but
my girl said i fell off the i fell off
the bed while he was eating me out and
he said five second rule
that's dead
i like that
i like that i like that i like that i
like that
oh this one
he said arch your back and i went the
wrong way
she did this thing
it took me a second
it took me
yuck
yuck
i'll spank a coccyx and leave i'll slap
it down bro a donkey puncher
uh her lumbar will get cracked
nah
[ __ ] oh that's that way
arch your back
sick it's hunching
i couldn't see that's embarrassing
that's embarrassing
that's embarrassing see from a bird's
eye right it's embarrassing that's where
the peach concaves
you don't want that
no i'm saying it that way oh yeah oh
that's hilarious that's hilarious
um
oh
i went the other way that's hilarious
nutted in my mouth and i gagged for five
minutes straight
damn son
damn son fam tubs did that happen to me
that's awkward you'll see me in the
covers like that that's awkward for both
parties i'll be sweating bruv nut in her
mouth and she's fight five minutes
that's ages bro just vomit if you're
gonna vomit
if you're gonna vomit [ __ ] vomit oh
my god imagine yeah yeah
i'm like
babes
he's sat there just
your diet is is
yeah yeah you need to change saturn
without you you need to change sides nah
fam you're eating like a slave
imagine five minutes found just
like all right man [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] gay [ __ ] well if i can get
it yeah my not squishy
let's laugh it up
let's laugh it out might not taste like
[ __ ] we get it oh it's hilarious that's
so embarrassing i would have to walk out
i'm not staying the whole five minutes
if she gags more than six times i'm out
i'm walking the [ __ ] out
oh my god oh
actually good question
have you ever had a girl spear out not
like in your presence or anything but
like go and spit it out
uh
not that i can recall i have when i was
younger okay
the thing is she had it was a weird one
because she had no issue with me not in
her mouth okay she just didn't want to
swallow it okay which is fine yeah
but
in that process of where you just not in
someone's mouth and their lap
and they just walk off to the bathroom
is that how she did it yeah if i'm she
would
ah
when you say how else are you gonna do
it i thought you meant like sexually
like spitter i thought that's what you
meant
no she literally got up and spat it out
and came back to the room yeah no
brother
that's never happened to me
one girl i wouldn't actually process
that don't you bear polite about it i
just don't want to swallow not and i'm
like that's fair that's a fair thing to
say but when you get up and spit it in
the sink it's i'm just
wow thank god i've already knotted
because we wouldn't be doing anything
yeah yeah it's done it's done after that
she used to love certain dick and she
she refused for you to just not not in
the mouth
but it's just she just didn't want to
swallow it
and i'm like i guess that's fine it is
what it is i guess it is but just like
it's very embarrassing
no it's never ever happened to me before
it's only happening with that one girl
and i wouldn't wish on my worst enemy
um
i've already seen it
he looked up whilst eating me out so i
waved at him no
just do
this
[Laughter]
that's worse fam imagine that's
hilarious
that's hilarious ah nah man now
that kills every everything everything
everybody i'll be sweetie so would i
we're not [ __ ] tonight just so you
know sweetie but it's like i'm clearly
not eating you out enough oh you're in
the you're just neutral you're here
you're not even you're not lost you're
present you're exactly you're you're not
lost and i'm that doesn't sit well with
you
[Music]
that just doesn't sit well with me
that you've still got the cognitive yeah
you're [ __ ] appearance to look down
and wave here fam
you can respond to emails that you're
blessed
it would it would be [ __ ] hilarious
you're mad coherent
you're
that reminds me of master of none okay
where there's an episode of mastering
now he's eating out his missus rachel
yeah and then just while she's in there
she's she's ready to pop okay man
pokes his head out the covers i think
this is like how's it going that rings
the face
funny as [ __ ] but ruins everything
she wants to knock him out yeah i can
imagine [ __ ] hilarious
i need to get into the character for
this one right
[ __ ]
he wanted to go under the blankets then
said
not even the ghosts can see us
[Laughter]
imagine
he would have gotten dry like that fam
like that absorbed all the moisture in
the air that
not even the ghosts can see us no oh
shame on you sir nice probably the
second or third time smashing period bro
oh god
last one
he covered my face with a pillow
just there fam
just suffocating the [ __ ]
nah
[Laughter]
that's uncalled for that's an uncalled
for king
smothering tingle i can see where your
head's at yeah but you can't do that
michael would die she would die my girl
will die um [ __ ] that give me a sec
right oh my head hurts now
my stomach is rumbling james i heard it
jesus i heard it bro i don't know why
you keep getting subways it's not
filling fam that's not finn it's not
eating subways
it's not even for real meat stop
[ __ ] off i'm content with the food i had
i'm not like i'm content i need i need
food now now wait um we're nearly done
we're on camera stop talking about
yourself
right
okay cool
i've got more x ridiculous amount
actually not even that many mix but it's
it's getting ridiculous okay but
before that i said on the patreon
episode i gave myself a egg
last week
i gave myself another egg yesterday okay
i'm confident in myself as a person and
my flaws
so i can say this with chess and i
embrace men just own your icks in it
yeah oh i said it before as well about
when i'm eating and it just runs down my
beard and blah blah blah yeah yeah
yeah own your ex
at this point there's so many of them
you just have to face your ex head on
yeah and just just if you're in that
situation it's like oh when i went ice
skating the other week i was icking
family i was just there bambi family and
i just thought there's literally nothing
i can do about it i'm just giving
everyone the ick and you know what [ __ ]
it we can't please everybody yeah fam
so your boy
was driving the other day
bro i'm not gonna lie to you
i had to bust doo doo fam i had to like
my stomach was aching yes it happens it
happens as it as it does yeah so pulled
up bp garage yeah bless service station
pulled up
ran into the toilet
did my thing
as i'm there
so boxes down trousers down
as i'm there
they must have a motion detector thing
the light is cut out
it was pitch
black through head pitch black
i haven't white haven't done anything
and i'm sat on the ball yeah legs in
hand like on one thing and i'm here like
this
fan the team were turning on the thing
was not turning on i was locked in this
pitch black cubicle just waving fam
waving knees buckled [ __ ] waving
anywhere
i was this close this close
help
this [ __ ] clothes bro if i didn't
have my phone torched on me literally
would have been there like help
help
ah that's hilarious the worst part was i
was thinking if someone walks in yeah
they're gonna know the lights weren't on
and then they're gonna find out that i
was in here with the lights bucket off
and they're gonna think what's going on
what's going on what in the glory hole
was going on in here
you can't make me laugh
what in the glory hole is going on the
[ __ ] here that's hilarious but yeah
anyway that's my egg i own it with my
chest guys when when we call your name
own it because these are coming hot and
fast bro
so when you find your ic raise your hand
and own it yeah
okay that's hilarious so
fam the visual of this
it's annoying because it might you know
my barbers right yeah yeah my barber's
got the same thing in his toilet it's a
motion detector thing yeah for the
lights but it cuts off literally three
seconds after you walk in it's [ __ ]
annoying just get a switch
i'm pissing now
and it cuts off and i'm going like this
but sometimes if i wave it doesn't have
to step back
it's like no i'm pissing big man yeah
yeah yeah so annoying so annoying cuts
off after three seconds all the time
that's all that is [ __ ] annoying
makes no sense oh yeah all right let's
get through these eggs guys guys i'm
sorry fam i'm sorry and the thing is you
know what yeah
we said before about our
girls versus guys x et cetera et cetera
et cetera and guys are sending in a few
more eggs but they're just not funny
enough they're not cutting it they're
just not funny
they're valid they're just not funny
enough and they're played out
it's the same one over and over again
women women in heels buckling yeah
everything we saw today that's what i
wanted to get it every day yeah we've
been seeing that dude yeah
we need a we need like [ __ ] chris
hemsworth to tell us some x
because he's drowning in the [ __ ] i
need dan bilzerian in here yeah he's got
a book a book full of ex clearly yeah
yeah yeah dan
i know you're watching
let us in on some x bro because these
men are through nepal so bad they can't
think of nothing else but buckling heels
man said i know you're watching
[Music]
that's jokes second biggest part in the
world i know you're curious you're
watching right
x yeah this is more tick tock x
oh god
when he's waiting for the live
wait i can't even see it
when he's waiting for the lifeguard to
let him go down the slide he saw that
brother
i saw that
he's just staring the slide just found
just waiting
waiting
in hand
i saw that oh
women are cut through women are [ __ ]
cutthroat right next up
oh
when he's trying to walk next to his
friends but the path is too narrow
so he has to step fans have to step into
the ah
step off the curb wait till they walk
past them days yeah
when you have to walk behind your
friends you are better oh yeah you're
fighting for that piece of curb
that gets me angry i hear that i lick my
chest i hear that oh this one's sweet so
[ __ ] specific bro
when he uses the chocolate box menu to
pick a chocolate
i like what i like in it
why is that in it brother i like what i
like when you refer to the menu
looking for that truffle
that caramel
oh let me because oh that's hilarious
i saw that one
i need to find which ones have jam so i
can avoid them
that's what i'm looking for
that's jokes man
that's so specific
when he stalls the car
i can imagine i can imagine that being
an egg yeah it's an egg for me bro
especially when it jolts
the suspension lets you rock in it for a
second as well
it's embarrassing [ __ ]
thank god for automatics
[Laughter]
this is me i raised my hand this is me
this is me my name's been called
they called me out
when he eats something hot and does that
the thing bella never waits for the food
to like if she wants something she wants
it now same thing if i'm cooking rice
and peas yeah she goes in the pot she
doesn't blow the spoon right
my tongue's burning from yesterday i
told you
i'm like come on i sucked the stew
yesterday my tongue's blistered bro
that's me to a t that's hilarious i blow
to my heart's content
i blow to my heart's content and then i
chew i'm not on it like that nah fam i
think if you blow it more than thrice
ick
if i'm if you've got the ladle and
the third
egg
man up and slap the ting from taste it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] i'm sweating i am sweating oh no
i've lost it where's it gone
um fam when he swims towards you
that to me
is an incredible ick
and i'll tell you why bro hit me i need
contacts i need to visualize it this
isn't swimming towards you but when i
was on this is this has to be holiday
based right okay it has to be hollow
this is not public pool okay this is
hotel pool right okay okay okay beach
sorry
when i went to irena years ago yeah
there was one chick selling tickets yeah
we were in the in the c family yeah i'm
talking a good hundred meters out okay a
bit shallow yeah so there's one chick
selling tickets she clocked us from
miles away from the beach we saw her a
direct line walk all the way from the
sand into the water as the water got up
to knee height waist height walking not
swimming stomach height walking titty
height walking until she literally got
two feet away from us and then she was
like
she took one stroke she walked the whole
way took one stroke i was like hi
most hilarious thing over me and my boys
ripped her a new [ __ ] bro
walked the entire way one breaststroke
oh hi
so if i'm as soon as i read that that's
what i remind him fair enough if you
clock a donny from across the hotel paul
praying you
and then swims all the way over
ah disgusting i can imagine that's not
something i've ever seen or experienced
or witnessed so i've never seen it apart
from that i can imagine i can imagine ah
right last one this one's peak
when the automatic door doesn't open so
he has to do the quick back and forth
[Laughter]
fam
walking up to a door that doesn't
acknowledge you as a human
is the most embarrassing thing
acknowledging
when you have to back up wait and then
go again
oh you're not a man uh that's the door
when a robot doesn't think you're a
human being you're not a man that's
annoying i can imagine that
it doesn't you don't even have enough
presence you don't have enough presence
to detect motion [ __ ] it out i've
thought of a nick for myself i've done
this many a times
i'm because he just reminded me when you
say walk up to the door and walking back
i've been walking on my phone trying to
find a spot
not knowing where it is you walk walk
walk with conf anything [ __ ] i'm going
the wrong way
i'm going the wrong way
he just immediately turned around all
right
done in bare times when you have done it
turn around in a public place i feel
like everyone knows yeah everyone
everyone knows everyone around me knows
that this going to family you slowly
turn you say [ __ ]
and then you turn the opposite direction
i'm waiting for someone to like nah
you're lost
he doesn't know where he's going
i waited for nelson from the simpsons
i'm in the whip and i'll do a big
circle back yeah
[ __ ] but anyway guys
as we said hold your head high raise
your hand if you got called out and um
we'll we'll see you on the next one we
love you very much patreon see you on
thursday
um yeah man level of love
[Music]